[ __ ] [ __ ]
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so Netflix
confirmed on their back end that
Punisher season 1 is coming 2017 so this
is going to be a breakdown they've
already announced their showrunner
they're already looking at a couple
characters so I'll just explain
everything if you didn't see it I did a
defenders trailer breakdown I talked a
little bit about how Jon Bernthal popped
his head in at Comic Con at the Netflix
panel and was just like hey everybody I
just wanted to say thanks
he had this super beard on it was
freaking huge but he's just so thankful
to the fans for the awesome response
that they gave him for his portrayal and
just reminding everyone 2017 Punisher is
coming he didn't say it officially but
they did say that we're working on
weaving Punisher into the larger
defenders universe because a lot of the
punisher stuff didn't blow up till after
they'd already made all these
contractual arrangements to produce the
defenders series and all the different
shows so before they ever rolled cameras
on daredevil season 1 they had contracts
in place for when each season would drop
how many episodes they'd be and when
they would team up in defenders so it's
almost like they planned a whole phase
of movies like they've been all the way
through The Avengers from the first Iron
Man movie ahead of time then when
Punisher came along and blew up everyone
went crazy they're like oh my god we
have to find a way to do more of this
well of course the answer is to do
spin-off series but they were so tied up
with the plans to make all these other
series that they had to adjust a little
bit so they're still kind of figuring
that out so even if it gets pushed a
little bit I still think that we'll see
Punisher season 1 before the end of 2017
it just might get pushed to the ass end
of 2017 so like November December so all
the new characters that Marvel can do TV
series for on Netflix Punisher is
probably the perfect fit and because of
the context with which they used him in
daredevil season 2 like the way they
introduced him into this universe
they're actually a number of really easy
jumping off points for where he can go
with his first season so like the
overarching villain the one who ties
everything together is Wilson Fisk he's
kind of like the Thanos of the Netflix
series even though he's only going to be
one of the villains of the defenders
team-up but during daredevil season two
he and Punisher had it out and he let
him know and no uncertain terms that the
minute he got out of prison he would be
gunning for Punisher just like he'd be
gunning for daredevil and for Nelson and
Murdock because even though you might
wonder kingpin does not know that Matt
Murdock is daredevil yet
he'll probably figure it out eventually
but it doesn't really matter because he
wants to kill both of them
so either way Matt Murdock is in deep
[ __ ] just like the Punisher is in deep
[ __ ] but the easiest sell in terms of
Punisher villains are the mop like that
was mostly what he did during daredevil
season 2 is he went after mob targets
that he felt were culpable in the death
of his family so naturally he killed a
couple of high-level people like the
Irishman when the Irishman threatened to
kill his dog oh man you just can't come
back from that the minute you threaten
someone's dog you have to die
that's the tv-shows way of telling you
that there's people out there that are
way worse than the Punisher as crazy as
the Punisher is you do not hurt animals
so I feel like a really easy thing for
them to do with Punisher is him going
after human traffickers because if you
remember during daredevil season 1 they
tried to bring in that black sky child
so there's a lot of human trafficking
that goes down at the docks Punisher is
just like the first person you would
expect to be on that now like daredevil
and Punisher do overlap a little bit
because the hand aside the biggest
villains in Hell's Kitchen in that area
of the city are drug dealers in the mob
the kingpin naturally is going to be
getting out of prison soon will start
consolidating mob forces so eventually
like all the different factions that you
saw during daredevil season 2 that the
Punisher was going after they will be
one faction united under Wilson Fisk
but I'm only expecting to see shades of
that as we move into the big defenders
team-up even if he's not the big bad of
the first season of the Punisher I feel
like it'll probably be a classic
Punisher villain like they'll go for the
easy slam Dunc it'll be jigsaw someone
who you're kind of familiar with but
also flows from a lot of the stuff
they've done so far if you didn't know
the showrunner has already been hired
he's coming from Hannibal I just love
the idea that the person who was
responsible for Hannibal Lecter is going
to be authoring Punisher season 1 in
there's rumors that microchip is going
to be part of the series he's kind of
like a Melvin Potter gladiator type
character someone who helps the Punisher
with weapons gear missions but then
later like in later series he becomes a
villain so they go up against each other
so there's a number of different ways
that the series could use him but so far
he's the only officially confirmed
character that they're looking at right
now but there'll be plenty more as they
start working on the series
so while defenders is the culmination of
all the different Netflix series so far
just expect all the series going forward
to weave in aspects of that so like
Jessica Jones season 2 which is going to
be happening after defenders will
acknowledge everything that happened so
far but it's not going to be tied to
what's going on on Luke Cage season 2 or
daredevil season 3 or Punisher season 1
it'll just like loosely weave in bigger
plot elements Wilson Fisk
in the hand or just the best examples of
that and for those that are asking we
haven't talked about it recently but
there is a Jessica Jones Season 2 that's
been greenlit it's going to have
multiple villains and it's going to
double down on the Hellcat Jessica Jones
friendship so for all of you that have
been holding your breath like really
hoping for Patsy Walker Hellcat stuff
we'll probably see more of that in
season 2 but as we get on in seasons
expect more characters to cross over
Heroes for Hire style like once we get
Luke Cage and iron fist obviously in the
next season of one of those shows we'll
probably see a whole bunch more iron
fist during the next season of Luke Cage
so let me know in the comments who do
you want the big bad of Punisher season
1 to be remember that they will follow
up on some of the consequences of what
Punisher did like Wilson Fisk is
definitely coming after him family
members of the Irish gang members that
Punisher killed might be coming for him
there will be repercussions so it's
going to be really fun to see how they
dance around all those things during
Punisher season one but he of all the
characters he will be the most under the
radar just because he doesn't hesitate
to kill people in related news my next
video is either going to be the flash
movie because they just announced that
cyborg is going to be a big part of that
or it'll be flash season 3 so be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll be doing both
videos I just haven't decided which
one's going to post first so you guys
can let me know which one you want first
in the comments what you guys wait for
my next video to post you can click here
for the Luke Cage trailer and you can
click here for my infinity war teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight